i just think you're doing fine with
dating the four women you want
just let them know what your intention
is and don't waste their time
i don't think i would make like a
three-hour date i i would start with
like
you know a coffee date or a walk right
because
you know chemistry's important and he
said oh
well i just got divorced i do not ever
want to get murdered again
i know your taxes i know the real
god this is what your experience was
write down what are the negative
imprints that i got
what how did what did they teach me
about what love is
they weren't bad guys they just weren't
the right to that
and if that's your vision and that's
what you want that's there's nothing
wrong with that and i'm sure you can
find a woman
i i'm going to tell you for some reason
um people
you work with special needs children